it's almost like I don't even have to be
here amazing this runs itself house girl
runs beer bath today I'm going to London
you're coming with me
I got texted waiting so yes we'll see
you when my face is not dark Oh am i
signing all of these right hey it's
gonna be a long day holy tries a lot of
us - alright we sign 2/3 I mean I sign
they didn't sign anything yeah they do
anything shares are lazy yeah this is it
this is the first signing but all you
guys are gonna go through here and then
I'm gonna be here yeah
all right the madness again I got my
security peeps with what Hey
hopefully you guys want do anything
weird things guys will step in
I'm excited gonna start how many people
Hey
no no all right we finished that it took
four hours I'm so tired
when we're looking for the bathroom it
was so much fun
I feel really emotional because I ruin
is so sweet and now I'm going to eat
buggies hey hey hey yeah No
okay that's end of day one really what
time is it what time is it it's nine
o'clock such a long day it was really
amazing though I was so heartwarming to
meet so many fence or Bros and I am just
happy but I'm very very tired so good
night
good morning it's 5:00 I'm very upset I
haven't slept at all and I have a long
day you know when you wake up and you
just look at the bed and you're just
excited for the date to be over so you
can be back in the bed
so you can go back and cuddle this sweet
little princess Amy she beat here with
me too baby empty me P my days in Italy
gives you one ring I had to say to do
the book thing I feel like I'm going
insane let's go alright so just finish
the first radio thing today make grimmy
beautiful pictures that you can't see
caffeine is keeping me alive right now I
don't know how I'll make it to the end
of the day but we'll see alright I just
wrapped up my live show my one hour
radio one takeover really fun enjoyed it
I was so terrible at Dairy it's like the
most simple thing you like slide up and
slide down I failed miserably so I had
this touchscreen it's amazing
and also it's almost like I don't even
have to be here it's amazing this runs
itself ok another promo done sugar
escape interview people walking by this
is great
what are you doing a lunch radio one
more promotion great all right we're at
Capitol hey guys hey we wrapped up the
radio stuff and now
lunch I hope we're done so much PR
within that right we are having lunch
over at penguin my publisher this was
being a historical building sup keep
burping this is a great block this
should be cool your brothers are coming
along holy crap that's amazing look at
this wow that's so cool so they're
telling me that Winston Churchill stood
on this balcony when the the Germans
were bombing to look out for the planes
and I can see why cuz look at this view
it's incredible
this morning I was so tired I'm still so
so tired but I'm having a lot of fun so
that's okay
it's really hard to keep my eyes open
here because I'm Swedish and we got a
lot of more interviews to do we're doing
a live stream on YouTube before my
channel later and yeah it's just PR all
day all night I I keep thinking about
the bed as soon as I like stay still for
one second I'm like look at this view I
can't get over it's so cool really
excited about the livestream I got more
energy now I'm eating Swedish Swedish
licorice which is the best thing in the
world so I'm happy happy man happy poche
last interviews done I did it now we
have the live stream
I can't believe if I was still awake do
I look tired yes I think I do so excited
realize dream though I hear Matthew
McConaughey is going to be there but
it's just a rumor
we'll have to see all right we're here
this is Google's building we're doing
the live stream here do you guys need
help with outfit I'm just pretending to
be nice okay there we go you to space
why am i entering a bubble or something
it's cool well look who's there look
who's there I found it yeah all right
this is the set we're gonna do the live
stream it's that no Matthew you made it
I'm so happy all right
I finished the day yes I a sneak peek of
the live stream in case you missed it
it's weird I can't believe I made it
through it today cuz it's been it's been
a long day to not sleep heading home now
so I'm on the wall names I was calling
yeah hi tiny
Chester see I'm above Chester see drama
who else am i above that girl and the
dog I'm right as freeze that's pretty
cold I feel like I should sign it before
I know this is great guys that's pretty
shitty signature great fun no that's
awful
well it's an honor I want to thank my
mom and that's it so this is the next
day I was so tired yesterday I just
crashed the I slept for so long and I
don't feel guilty one second my aunt
hey hey man a lot of people a lot of
your brother likewise my aunt a marine
your blocks because she's always sleepy
she's my era I'm reading all the reviews
of the book finally uh and on Amazon and
they are so funny I'm so glad that you
brought I feel like it was really get it
cuz even though you know the joke the
jokes are very sarcastic and very mean
but and it's supposed to be a book about
self-help but they are funny and they're
supposed to make you laugh and that's
the point so I know that got a lot of
people confused when I was doing
interviews yesterday so I was a little
bit worried but I feel like a huge
weight is lifted on my shoulder so thank
you both for supporting the book it's
out in bookstores now so go outside
can't believe I'm telling you to go
outside go outside it to your local
bookstore and see if you can find it I
think it's so cool that I can I can give
you Bros something that you can enjoy
and that you can hold and and then
that's why I really wanted to do this
book I just think it's awesome this is
just the beginning of the book tour we
have so many more places to go but now I
get three days to rest so I'll see you
bros in three days as always stay
awesome wait actually I got a sho look
at Edgar boats why don't you let me go
up I love you I love you too idea but
we're going outside
so here it's good for you
I love it down a little bit but every
more would be wrong I love a little bit
to your right one thing
yeah
a